wir haben darüber gesprochen ob das noch
so richtig ist dass deutschland das
richtig gut macht sie haben ja
verschiedene blickwinkel noch leben in
der schweiz wie gesagt und sie waren
jetzt gerade kürzlich wieder dort wo
ihre wurzeln her kommen sozusagen in
vietnam und das ist ganz erstaunlich wie
die entwicklung dort ist was haben sie
da gesehen wie man mit der krise umgeht
in vietnam herr rösler auch in der tat
sind die zahlen haben alle sehr gut
man hat nur 57 todesfälle zu beklagen
aufgrund von corona und auf 97 millionen
einwohner
auch nur insgesamt 1700 fälle also
selbst wenn man eine gewisse
dunkelziffer da mit einrechnet sind die
zahlen doch nach wie vor im weltweiten
vergleich sehr gut
ich glaube man hat zu anfang sehr hart
reagiert wie übrigens viele asiatischen
staaten und hat sofort die grenzen dicht
gemacht und hat wenn du ein einziger
fall irgendwo aufgetaucht ist ganze
regionen quasi beim lockdown belegt das
hat dazu geführt dass man die erste
welle gut beherrschen konnte und als man
dann im sommer aus ein bisschen
gelockert hat und dann auch wieder erste
fälle aufgetreten sind es gab einen fall
in einer touristengegend einen einzigen
fall darf man dann gleich 70 tausend
touristen ausgewiesen um sozusagen
gleichen vorne ein
das virus einzudämmen das hat dann
gefüllt so dass man jetzt im land selber
sehr viele freizügigkeiten hat aber nach
wie vor zu dem preis dass von außen
eigentlich fasten mit rein darf
bis auf ganz wenige ausnahmen und dann
auch nur unter wirklich was sie in
quarantäne maßnahmen